if you could just kind of walk us
through sort of like what the program is
and then I'd just love to hear about
sort of how you got there and stuff but
like yeah just tell uh so positive
change is a comprehensive inmate canine
training program that we developed to
help give hope and opportunity to
incarcerated people and pets um I
founded Marley's muts 14 years ago you
know we started positive change almost
eight years ago okay um positive change
started after a friend of mine got out
of prison uh 13 years incarcerated at 17
got out and he was
and it was had very much been worn down
by the prison system he was nearly feral
when he got out of prison I don't mean
to say that disparagingly I just meant
it was very difficult for him to have
personal relationships to to talk to a
man without having some sort of a
complicated size up scenario to to
interact with a woman all of these
things were brand new to him and he you
know wrestled with drugs in prison and I
gave him a dog when he got out dog that
I was fostering Shadow she had been uh
she had been shot in the chest we had to
remove two loes of her lungs she's just
a beautiful Pitbull and that dog changed
everything about his life Wow changed
every aspect of well first it gave him
the ability to love himself and it gave
him the ability just like it did when I
was getting sober to take one step at a
time with your dog with you when you
were too intimidated or scared to do it
on your own C can you explain that yeah
I mean for I think for a lot of us who
are whether it's newly sober or if
you've been incarcerated there is a for
me anyway I was scared of people places
and things terrified of people places
and things I did not know how to
have you know whether it be vulnerable
interactions or just day-to-day
interactions with people sober I had not
been sober my entire life right but my
dog Marley just like Shadow did for him
allowed me to to face the day allowed me
to to put one foot in front of the other
get myself out of my shell and start to
have interaction start to go to the
market start to go to the the hospital I
bring my dog everywhere yeah and and it
started to help me break loose of that
oppressive those that oppressive feeling
that just kept me locked inside of
myself it's you know by myself um the
simplest things were difficult trying to
go to the supermarket trying to do
anything I needed to do for myself was
was terrifying you give me my dog you
give me a 95lb rottweiler
pitbull I can breathe um if say I'm I'm
interacting with you if if I'm nervous
about the interaction and we got our dog
to talk about we have some common
denominator we can relate about that and
nine times out of 10 people always want
to relate about your dog sure you know
if it's just two people talking
especially if there's no alcohol
involved it might be kind of awkward you
might struggle through a little bit of
the you know especially if that's been a
part of the way that you've interacted
for so long when you take something out
there's a big hole thereally and you
fill it with that dog and then you you
introduce a a dog like that and you got
something to talk about you're talking
about their dog you're talking about him
and all of a sudden you have this bond
this friendship this common denominate
that you're bonding over and uh for me
that was critically important and for
Robbie it was as well and his life I
mean when I met him there was there was
very little eye contact there was I
could tell this was a person that was
really struggling to understand where he
fit in society and then after we gave
him shadow he started giving his
testimony with me he started speaking
about his incarceration he started
speaking about his recovery he started
talking about his experience as a as a
gang member he started talking about his
all of these things and you just saw him
grow and
and and I think he would tell you his
experience was as well as what mine was
is that I I started to be able to to
love myself you know you you um you
can't have a dog like that a bond with a
dog like that that is just feeding you
undying unconditional love and not have
some of it land you know and and have
you start to love yourself some and for
me that was that my lifelong struggle is
loving myself that is my lifelong
struggle but for whatever reason when
when that blinding love is communicated
through a dog's eyes and through a dog's
body language it it lands and you kind
of feel yourself I don't know if You'
ever done this but man if I've had a day
I come home and I crawl on the ground
with my
Beta I just feel it you oh God right do
you know and you root down into that
love and you root down into that
vibration dogs have just the the best
vibration man yeah yeah so um yeah I
mean to make a long story short I saw
Rob you know when Robbie got out of
prison he had very little hope that he
was going to succeed there was not much
you know out there for him you give him
that dog and he starts to build
confidence he starts to build
self-esteem he starts to build
experience he starts to to face fears
that he didn't think he could face and
then all of a sudden we've hired him and
then after you know he was our Ranch
manager he went on to start his own
organization called strength of Shadow
so now he's you know a formerly
incarcerated gang member to a nonprofit
you know director and and and making an
incredible impact in his community and
so after that you know I knew that we
had to try to get rescue dogs into
prison and I I knew that was something
that if we could just figure out how to
do it it would it would change
potentially tens of thousands of lives
you know and and really give us a way to
save a lot of dogs that otherwise
couldn't be saved but it was hard man we
spent four years trying to get into the
prison system you know we started at
Laro County Jail in Kern County we we
tried at to hatch State Prison and we
just kept getting we were greeted with
brick walls I mean there was no um
interest in not only dog programming but
really anything that was um sort of pro-
inmate or could be potentially viewed as
pro- inmate uh so when we finally had uh
Warden David long over at California
City Correctional Facility he took a
gamble on us and he said uh you know I I
love what you guys are trying to put
together let's work on on making this
operational procedure fit and I want you
guys at my prison and so January 2016
with the help of some of the best
trainers on the planet Leah Marquez Lisa
Porter Kim Ericson
uh Sam Johnson we were able to start
that program and um we had 30 student
inmates 10 dogs right off the euthanasia
list living in that prison and
rehabilitating every three months so
it's a it's a 14- week long program we
send dogs basically from the shelter
system from usually from the euthanasia
list and usually large young dogs wow
like your dog wow those are the dogs
that are being put to sleep at our
shelters that's right and they're being
put to sleep at our shelters because
they don't have the skills to be adopted
and stay adopted whether that's lease
training you know potty training crate
work they might be reactive with other
dogs so there's so much that these dogs
need to understand in order to get
adopted and stay adopted and that's what
we were able to accomplish in the
program and and how do you so so I uh
and I mean there's so many parallels
between you know th those dogs the the
the the fear the the the the the bigotry
the the you know how how people perceive
those kinds of dogs and how you know
people perceive these kinds of inmates
how do you I mean how do you choose
specifically how do you what's a
criteria in choosing the dog and what's
a criteria in choosing the inmate or is
it just whoever signs up for it well in
the uh in the early days when we first
started we sent everybody into prison so
the worst of the worst dogs because our
trainers were so good that we were able
to get some of our long-term
incarcerated students um trained up very
quickly so after our first 14-week long
program you know we were just rapid fire
every 14 weeks we're graduating a class
of 30 students we're letting them re
list so some of our guys are in our
program for years and years and years
they went through through 10 11 12
rounds they've saved tons of dogs they
they are
professional dog trainers so in the
beginning we send in the worst of the
worst I mean dogs that quite honestly we
should not have been sending in person
because there are there are a lot of
different variables that you can't
control when it comes to other
individuals um and these dogs so we did
have some some bites we had some some
things that were pretty tough but we had
the we have insurance
and we have the support of the
institution um but for the most part the
dogs that we're sending in now are
straight from the euthanasia list so
they're either dogs that are at our
Ranch we have a 20 acre ranch right next
door to tby State Prison literally we
share a border with them um and and it's
it's we are sending in the neediest of
the needy because young dogs are being
euthanized at a at a clip of about 40%
so 40% of young large dogs are being
killed in our County that's thousands
and thousands and thousands a year at
Great cost to our County so if if we
have any hope to get these dogs adopted
they have to have the skills to get
adopted and stay adopted so that's what
positive change does it's a 10 it's a a
14-week long program where we're
adhering to the K9 good citizen
certification so every week we're
working on a different point of the cgc
test so we're going through basic
obedience we're going through a
challenging group of steps to try to get
to our end goal which is Canine Good
Citizen certification and graduating the
program so there's socialization there's
mastering the walk there's learning the
the 3DS of dog training there's learning
um all these different aspects of dog
psychology that we're trying to convey
and the goal obviously is to help these
dogs get adopted and stay adopted but
it's also to provide much needed like
soft skills for our student inmates as
well as hard skills that they can take
out into the world and find gainful
employment right out of the gate to make
sure they don't end up back in
[Music]
prison